I feel like I'm Kim Kardashian with all
these cameras am i keeping up the cash
ins I think for the most part like as
far as like YouTube goes I'd rather just
try new characters or be myself and that
sort of thing just because like like you
said I'm 19 playing a six-year-old so I
mean which is fine but it's just like I
think I've done so many fried videos I
just want to try new things I think most
of my fans want to see new things hey
guys its Lucas here how are you guys up
whoa whoa Fred please get out I guess
now that I've been working with
Nickelodeon and that sort of thing I've
realized I've gotten older and realize
like how young my fans are and that sort
of thing and like the ages they range
from I've been like more conscientious
of like what I say in my videos of what
I tweet but honestly when I first
started making Fred videos I didn't
think anything of that because i was 13
i wanted to make it for people my age 13
year olds and i was just i said whatever
and like when i watch those videos i'm
like wow like i don't think i would like
have enough guts to say that now like
what i said in those videos so i think
just like over the years like
subconsciously like I think I've became
more filtered but it's always weird to
think that like when I think about like
the world like I feel like most people
in the world know me is Fred and not as
Lucas it is actually kind of cool i
think that they don't like no like my
real name or whatever cuz it's kind of
just like shows that they really
connected with the character and it's
funny cuz sometimes all seem really
little kids and no I'll be like oh my
god your friend number like yeah it's me
or whatever but then love you so
disappointed that i don't have the voice
and they're like why are you why are you
not wearing your one shirt and like
where's your mom or whatever and that
sort of thing so it's funny like seeing
how different ages connect with it it's
so weird and i see people with Fred
shirts and I think when they first came
out there was a stage where like I'd see
it a lot like if I was an amusement park
or the mall I see someone in a Fred
shirt and it was just like so weird
walking past then we sometimes they
won't even notice felt like I was a
divine month they were wearing or
whatever but also one time was it like a
flea market someone like had all this
Fred merchandise and that they were just
like selling illegally so I thought that
was funny I think the reason why Fred on
transferred to tea
so well is because the Fred character
had like such a world around it i mean
like there was the mom there's all these
kids at school and i feel like there was
just such a big world to like kind of
make a full length movie off of it
wasn't just like one character screaming
the whole time which it kind of looks
like at first I don't really think
YouTube is that place anymore where you
go to it to get a TV show or get a
record deal or whatever you're trying to
do I think being on YouTube is just
enough because it's such a huge thing I
mean they're getting so many views and
they have such a big fan base is like
why wouldn't you want to stay on you too
i think it's almost better than TV of
such more intimate connection and you
get to see what your fans say instantly
and all of that so I mean if they wanted
to do a TV show they could do it in a
second but I mean I think it's better to
stay on YouTube personally
you
um I think my perception of YouTube has
changed a lot over the years because I
mean when I first started making videos
it was just a place for me to I guess
just put my videos and that's something
I thought I thought it was like myspace
or facebook or something we're just your
friends could see it but then obviously
I realized that so many other people
could watch it and that sort of thing
and i was making videos like every week
and doing it like really right girly and
then I think once I got success on TV at
kind of like I was so busy with that and
I kind of forgot about you two but I was
like all my fans will sue me on TV like
maybe I don't need to like make so many
YouTube videos but i don't really like
regret anything in life but I mean
obviously like I probably should have
stayed more engaged with my youtube fan
base and kept it going and all of that
sort of thing but I guess that's kind of
what I'm trying to do now is get my
youtube fan base back up because I mean
I think a lot of people on YouTube think
I like betrayed them or like whatever
they think I'm the sellout and that sort
of thing but I mean when I was like 14 I
got offered to do these TV things and I
always wanted to be an actor like
obviously I was going to take that
opportunity and that sort of thing I
really was too young to understand like
keeping engaged with your fan base and
that sort of thing I just think it's
like funny how people view it because
they don't know the whole story I don't
really think it ever really hits me
which i think is good because i'm when i
first started getting a lot of
subscribers on youtube like it would i
would kind of like think about like oh
my god I have so many subscribers and
when I was making a video I'd be like
all nervous I got to feel like a million
people were watching and making the
video but I think you kind of just have
to not think about that side of it I
guess when you're creating Marvin Marvin
is basically about an alien from outer
space who comes live with this American
family it's just basically about him
trying to fit in at school and that sort
of thing I feel like everyone in high
school kind of feels like they're an
alien so it was kind of just like
hardcore exaggerating that I've honestly
never worked on a project were like
everyone actually gets along so well so
it's been so much fun and as far as now
I think we're just waiting to hear if
there's going to be a season two and
that sort of thing
when I first started making videos for
as long as I wanted to like be an act or
like a writer crater or whatever I never
have envisioned myself being the creator
for kids or performer for kids or any of
that I think it kind of just happened
honestly because when i created friday
was 13 so I was that age of the market
so I was just making it for me put my
age and obviously being 19 I have a
different like sense of humor now and
I'm into different things and that sort
of thing and it's so weird I really
think about it like that I mean I grew
up like watching the kids choice awards
and I was such a big fan of it so it's
weird that like now I'm nominated for an
award but I mean it just I think it's
all just things to all the fans on
YouTube and all of that and all the fans
of the TV show who have made it possible
cuz i mean honestly without like my
first like huge group of fans i wouldn't
be anywhere because they like hard they
spread the word about Fred and all of
that so I'm just so thankful for them
thank you guys for watching if you want
to check out the full ver an interview
and the photo shoot go to new media
rockstars calm and don't forget to
subscribe like and comment